Paco, like any good developer,
prefers to work
on the application
on his own machine.
This avoids synchronizing
database files and records
with a remote server
every time a change is made.
LOCAL ADMINISTRATION PANEL
Among some other tools
that we'll see
in future lessons,
the SDK includes
an administration panel,
which makes Paco's work
with his local
application easier.
This panel allows him
to explore the information
he adds as he advances
with the development,
and it allows him to monitor
and control various components
of the local
development environment.
Paco can access
the administration panel
by entering the address
localhost:8000 in his navigator
after having launched
the development server.
The first screen of the panel
shows Paco
the number of instances
locally serving his application.
In this case, just one,
in addition to some statistics
that said instance
has served until now.
If Paco, on another tab
of his navigator,
now loads his application,
he will see that
the number of applications
attended to by the instance
increases.
On the left is
the navigation panel menu,
through which
the different tools offered
can be accessed.
For example, from the
Datastore Viewer section,
quick data consults can be made
and thus, the records
saved on his local application
can been seen
in a pleasing format.
He will have the chance
to create, modify and eliminate
records without having
to write additional code.
From the Datastore Indexes
section he will be able to see
additional information
for his records,
such as, for example,
the amount of space used
by the indexes created.
The panel also has
an interactive console,
with which Paco
can execute code
in the language
corresponding to the SDK
directly downloaded
to the development environment.
With this interactive console,
he can obtain environment
information quickly,
register testing information
in Datastore
or test small fragments of code
before including them
in his script.
For example, to see the included
Python routes by SDK,
Paco imports the SYS library,
and quickly prints it.
He can also see other aspects
of the application,
such as the App Engine
environment variables.
Paco will use
the local administration panel
to help him in many ways
while he develops
the census application.
This will be even more useful
when he has some test results
registered in the Datastore,
Memcache, or uses task sequences
to implement different parts
of his application.
For now, try to take a look
at the different panel sections,
and review how starting
the local development server
will be a fundamental tool
in the following lessons.
Until next time.
Keep programming.
KEEP PROGRAMMING!